well we got heber and mars the buttery
bros
jillian butter bros uh my homies we you
know where we met where is the butter
bros or buttery brownies
because they are buttery yeah because by
the way they're the color of butter yeah
they're they look like the first thing i
said when i looked at them and i went
well grass-fed butter that's the first
thing raspberry butter with hamburgers
yeah because their skin couldn't be more
buttery yeah and i think you said that
as well yep buttery voices they've got
clear eyes and full hearts
full hearts and as a i have to say this
as a crossfit dilettante dabbler admirer
from afar
i've seen i didn't realize this until
this morning i've seen all your
documentaries on fitness i told you i
told you when i when i came back from
the tough mudder because i met them at
the tough mudder because i did that with
mark
and the like organizer with tough mudder
was like hey uh do you mind running with
the uh buttery bros and i was like what
and they were like you and i was like
are they really in good shape she said
oh yeah and i was like uh i'll probably
lay in the back like no i'm gonna
introduce you so you guys come back
[ __ ]
well i know you're with jason too who's
[ __ ] yeah redville
oh
yeah it's those three but then we were
all like it was it's weird the tough
mudder is great because you're like a
team yeah it was like that's a lot more
about the experience than like trying to
set a time to beat or anything you're
all getting shot when you showed me them
on the thing i thought to be honest i
thought you were just you were like
instagram influencers with nice spots
did i find out
i told you though i came out i'm like
dude they're beasts well they're legit
filmmakers yeah oh yeah
again i've seen literally all of your
work except for your latest one
i know all that matt frazier and and i
mean all the all these people that i've
admired all these crossfit athletes
but even on their their youtube uh the
buttery bros youtube like i send clips
to my team like bro we gotta step our
game oh dude thanks oh yeah keep it
coming yeah [ __ ] my tires have a good
time man where did the name buttery bros
come from so for a while we worked at
four crossfit headquarters as filmmakers
and and producers there and we'd be
shooting stuff uh around the sport and
anytime we'd be shooting something and
it was well composed and well shot and
smoothed and sometimes in slow motion
like hey come check out the shot it's
buttery oh and so then when we were
starting our own thing it was like we
shoot all butter all the time so that's
the official name of our company is all
butter and then for our youtube
specifically it was buttery bros because
god that makes a couple of bros yeah and
you got that you got that sort of mormon
slash germanic discipline yeah he's the
mormon you know straight teeth and
crooked smiles yeah i appreciate that
yeah you wouldn't think it because
you're going to be missionary haircut
right now yeah
i could peddle something long hair
frowned upon in the morning i don't know
too much about mormons i have mormons in
my family my mom keeps trying to tell me
that i need to cut it and i'm like i've
seen pictures of jesus
i would kill for hair like that me too
how about i would [ __ ] dude
hey i would kill for you to have here
right yeah i want that for you what
happened i've been
dude i'm so depressed i was watching me
do those burpees and the the light was
on my head yeah i couldn't look more
balls a little more
on the dome could be a little you could
tell me that i didn't i thought you knew
i don't know
yeah but like a red like yeah i got a
little [ __ ] strawberry you're a
russian
politician yeah i'm not happy with my
head dude moose in the clear i thought
you knew what was going on
it doesn't really cover when you're 54
you know that next year it's not better
you guys can still be like next year i'm
gonna put on five pounds a month and get
a little stronger for me you're just
trying not to [ __ ] your pants i'm trying
yeah
i woke up this morning between those
boys yeah i woke up this morning and my
my
32 year old fiance said you look like
you're made of wood your your feet are
you wearing clogs imaginary clogs
because i i had to warm my [ __ ] feet
up and i would point you out it only
gets worse from here girl only gets
worse from here and then i said really
and i turned around she went
you're a lot younger from the waist down
yeah all right there you go this is nice
yeah i invited you to the workout today
because we did a workout with these guys
i didn't want to embarrass myself i know
you i you had been fine we to be honest
we could have used you yeah we could use
you because the way we did it yeah is
they did our meat head stuff first the
first half was army so like strong
strong speaking of which he benched
things
man four plates man well don't get into
that he's bam bam he he's yeah
he's he's got he's got that gorilla
strong he's a silverback and the rest of
us are monkeys we understand that right
yeah he's on a different level trees
sleep on the ground
we throw our fruit at him and sometimes
he makes fun of me sometimes our poo
yeah but we're in the branches yeah
we're in the branches
and he's a ground dweller yeah but but
but they got us they got us i mean they
they did fine on the bench but then we
the last half was the more
kind of dynamic cardio crossfit now
chappelle's
crossfit so
it was the thick boys versus the buttery
bros okay three on three and mark was
there mark was there okay the big mark
very curious now mark but now see mark
has a [ __ ] up back so marco is not 100
his burpees
bother me but the thing is
is so you would sprint down on a sled
sprint back and then you gotta do ten
burpees and the other person can't start
to that person's dying oh that's a
nightmare and we were all right on the
sprints but then the the burpees the
burpees
well chappelle yeah chappelle i hate to
point fingers but
he was he was a little toasty after too
you know
rolling around when i look at chappelle
i think unique i think comic i think
strong i think backflip but i don't
think endurance yeah now some of you
guys should know about chappelle he's a
world champion uh cheerleader that's
what he said straight up like skinny
world champion cheerleader wow so on
stage like our fans know so he's my
feature so when he goes on the road with
us he'll get done he'll crush it and the
crowd will go back flip back flip and
then his big ass
backfire
holy [ __ ] oh here you go
is it right here yeah he's wrong there's
a bunch here the chappeller wesley oh
wow is that wesley snipes any more
questions yeah man yeah yeah i did not
no he he's a badass dude whoa he's in
san jose tonight you fox go see him san
jose san jose improv he's headlined his
own show tonight i would love for him
that is amazing i would have loved to
have seen this oh yeah he'll do that
right even a cartwheel so
i don't know if he'll do that now his
cardio is not he likes to skateboard now
wow yeah he's a freak i mean man the
[ __ ]
i mean come on wow that's so phenomenal
human being like the body awareness to
do that is so impressive and then this
holding here it gets dangerous
yeah he's a badass wow
oh look at that
shredded shred city
yeah he was there man
but uh you know these days you know look
father time
gets to us all
father's time and food and food yeah
yeah
yeah and and uh i'm not gonna be the
same after my burpees
yeah like we walk in
you know introduce ourselves and you're
like hey yeah what do you know about
birds did you feel like guilt because
you missed the workout and you wanted to
flex a little on them
uh i just i walked in and i saw them and
i went i got excited about crossfit and
i and i was excited about because i was
such a fan of their work and i you know
sometimes you if you're thinking about
crossfit i went for a walk this morning
so and i just had some energy i got a
little secret i and i want to talk to
you about this you don't drink coffee no
do you know what magic mind is now have
you ever known me to take anything ever
anything in all time
yeah besides steroids but have you ever
known me to take besides a lot of juice
but i've never i don't take any
supplements i i just don't i don't
believe in them it's not that i don't
believe in them i just i just never
don't think you need them right okay so
there's a guy who made all the money in
the world uh he he's this huge angel
investor and he had a hard thing so he
couldn't drink coffee anymore and i love
coffee so he comes up with this thing
called magic mind which is quarter set
mushrooms lion's mane and different
different um things it's it's think
alpha brain but but
the the four sigmatic it's not for sigma
have you had four sigma i have i've
tried these
i i this this [ __ ] your hair is magic
hair though i don't want to talk about
it it makes me sad jesus christ
just makes sense
i want to see if he can take this 50 50
and his pace kept up the whole time
it was a good pace right and the jump
that's the impressive part you guys were
so awesome because you were like
cheering me on yeah and the other thing
is like as you're coming down you're
slowing yourself so you're getting that
load on the way down where i just drop
and put my chest uh i let gravity
you don't want to wig
you watch that and you have no interest
in wigs hey hey man
hey it's not even a conversation
hey
don't say wig to me it makes me mad i'm
not getting a wig i will get another
hair transplant if i have to but if you
could if you don't mind first of all i
didn't know i was working with that and
you've never told me that and then you
let me i assume
you let me in that lighting you let me
get filmed like that you're not a friend
i gotta be honest with you dude you're
not a friend and you quietly enjoy this
[ __ ] you look good like a sick bastard
now did i get bummed out when you get
really zoomed in on that don't look at
that [ __ ]
[ __ ] everybody in this room dude i'm
supportive
like k-bubble i turned 55 in january
i went quietly how long we
oh and ian dyson i might die
yeah but that's what i mean
yeah that's why he's doing 50 purposes
and your mom like your mom's in good you
know
and i still have time to get on
testosterone and other [ __ ] which we
haven't done yet i've been putting it
off
maybe yeah i know this is a little
touchy subject for you yeah
but
two out of three men will experience
some form of hair loss by the time the
thirty yeah well that'd be me buddy yeah
i know and we saw what i looked like
under those lights and i'm dude you
could have saved it balder by the day
dude you could have saved it because
what do i do get a hair transplant
prevention is key but for you it's too
late but keeps for you other people that
don't look like brian my friends at
keeps they offer a simple stretchy way
to keep your hair it's low-cost
treatments start just ten dollars per
month keep offers generic versions all
right keeps has more five-star reviews
than any of the competitors prevention
is key don't be like brian and by the
way treatments can take four to six
months to see results and you will see
results when you take keeps what happens
is it takes a while but you will
actually save your hair and you can grow
new hair that is yes
so if you're ready take action prevent
hair loss go to k-e-e-p-s dot com slash
to receive your first month of treatment
for free that's keeps.com fighter to get
your first month free k-e-e-p-s dot com
slash fighter yeah
look cbd oil they say is very good for
dealing with stress anxiety pain i know
you have a history i use it every day
dude my kiddo still takes every freaking
day but you got to trust who you're
getting it's going to be it's got to be
pure it's got to be it's got to be very
good right yeah it feels feels a better
way to feel better yes feels is premium
cbd that will help you keep your head
clear and feel your best it's
hassle-free delivered directly to your
door yeah all right and i just placed a
few drops on your tongue and you're off
to the races reduce the stress that's
healthy pain sleeplessness no hangover
or addiction yeah i like fields has a
monthly membership makes it super easy
you save money on every order and you
can pause or cancel anytime you want so
start feeling better with feels become a
member today by going to feels.com
fighter that's f f-e-a-l-s dot com slash
fighter you'll get 50 off your first
order with free shipping
that's feels.com
fighter to become a member get 50 off
automatically taking off your first
order free shipping fields.com fighter
f-e-a-l-s you know yeah and i still have
time to get on testosterone and other
[ __ ] which we haven't done yet i've been
putting it off but just think about me
on [ __ ] test dude dude
dude i told him i'd roll your skull big
trt
okay don't say wig though it makes me
mad
i don't like what you say you're gonna
be sylvester stallone
no i'm not man because he's a lot older
dude
i'm still young
anybody who knows about hair transplants
give me a call i need the best
it's it's interesting you gotta go
turkey yeah you gotta go turkey yeah
okay so you're you're a mormon yeah get
back to this yeah i wanna know if you're
allowed are you allowed to do this so
you can't take stimulants
so the these are the rules the rules are
like it's kind of vague and it's an
older scripture that came out in the
1830s right so it's not like specific
and the so the general idea behind the
scripture in my opinion so i'm
interpreting that right so take that as
you would is to not have any addictions
to have complete control over your body
your temple yes and so if you're reliant
on
uh coffee or tea or or like i drink rain
i drink an energy drink and like
if i'm addicted to that that to me is a
problem so it's not necessarily like
they don't want you to drink coffee they
don't want to have any uh to drink
alcohol because they want you to be in
full control of your body and what your
body needs to be able to to perform at a
high level but if you talk what's the
opposite of mormons that's what i am
yeah
i do nicotine before i saw you guys i
did eight shots of espresso okay i did
i've already had whiskey today
uh you name it dude the opposite am i
going to hell i don't know i'm gonna i
want to see what you think of magic mind
i want to know why i use force in matter
i'm just obsessed with it
because it's the only thing i've ever
done that actually replaces coffee so
it's like a pill like no no bring it up
bring it up it's [ __ ] matcha so it's
just like green tea but then it's got
lion's mane it's got cortisone mushrooms
which i got into when i was doing it
when i had it from on it that the [ __ ]
like gives you more endurance whatever
the [ __ ] it is i just it's a drink it's
a drink matcha adaptogens nootropics
yeah like green tea is like a trigger
for i think a lot of mormons dude this
[ __ ] is a green tea kind of a gray area
no i i think i think just tease our yeah
so could you do could you do these are
okay but green teas are like kind of a
no are you really are you allowed to do
like uh like adaptations like uh that
decrease stress and stuff like that yeah
and that's that's what i'm saying is
like they haven't like come out with a
list of like you can take this this this
right like the general idea is like okay
we're gonna give you uh the general idea
of what you want to achieve and let you
kind of govern yourself right i mean
that's a good this is like it's a bottle
this [ __ ] big yeah i'm curious and so
for me like i'm like hey i might take
some things or drink some things that
might not be on that list if they wrote
it out yeah but i take care of the other
95 of what's healthy about how much i'm
eating or what i'm eating where a lot of
people that would probably say like hey
you shouldn't be drinking that with them
well i don't think this is this isn't a
stimulant like kevin because the guy who
invented it has a heart thing yeah so he
he that's why he did it and he did it
the what i like about him is he didn't
do it for money he has all the money in
the world he did it for himself it's a
stack he was doing for years oh wow and
i'm yeah so that and the doctor said you
can take this
because he was drinking like seven cups
of coffee he's like one of those guys
who made 500 million dollars and by the
time he's 29. and and the doctor was
like so he goes he he did all this
insane research and found out something
that doesn't and so the reason i like it
is it doesn't it doesn't give you that
caffeine high yeah it just gives you
that [ __ ] it's the only thing i've
ever done where i'm like so it's just
like a little it's like a green it's
that [ __ ] big but it's like what
about sugar is that frowned upon mormon
well that's where i would say like no
that's not a list where i would i would
kind of argue that hey i think there's
an over consumption of that and people
are addicted to that yeah and they're
not they're not they don't draw
attention to that but they'll draw
attention to green tea where there might
be some benefit from that so so
in my opinion like i don't worry so much
about i don't even tell i don't tell
anyone what to do or not to do but my
suggestion would be hey take care of
what you're actually consuming on like
for food and nutrition like with your
because you have two kids about five and
seven five and seven with sugar do you
limit sugar for them i
sort of i mean at this point i'm just
trying to get them to eat
yeah in a row sure well so you'll eat
yeah and you guys deal with the fittest
athletes in the world so their nutrition
has got to be crazy on point right it's
crazy how different they all are oh
really like some athletes are very
dialed in they know what macros they're
eating they're concerned about where
they're coming from and then others like
they just trust like matt the the
five-time world champion what about
bringing up matt fraser i i can be
honest i don't know the crossfit world
yeah i don't know i could bring up
brooke under the head like a million
dollars name one crosstalk
really closely for a really long time
and matt his incredible wife sammy cooks
for him and i don't think he pays
attention at all to what's he eating he
just trusts that she's provided enough
caloric intake for her because they're
because they're burning so many calories
and they just need to like yeah i guess
yeah he does what's his nationality
what a canadian yeah i think he was born
how tall is he he's like five eight
five seven right there five seven one
ninety five and he's a beast huh dude
he's he's
freak out like the amount of work is
selling
and almost everything he almost doesn't
have any weaknesses oh dude you got to
watch him you got to watch their you got
to watch their docks that's what makes
him so impressive is the fact that they
can give him any type of test and he's
swimming running sprinting
yeah and
he would take his weaknesses and make
him a strength so like one year he goes
out and takes like
out of 40 people he takes 36 and a
sprint jesus christ next year second
place in the sprint it's like insane and
i think that he's just smarter than the
rest of the competition because a lot of
a lot of super athletes will like hit
workouts and then you get to the end of
the workout and you'll be like what were
you trying to accomplish there what was
the intent and they'd be like i don't
know just to like do the workout and get
it done he's like no that's not the
right way to think about this you got to
be like going into every workout there
has to be an intention and you got to
know exactly what you're trying to get
out of it and he's the best at that and
i think that he's
you know now training a bunch of
athletes now he does it full time so he
he's actually written he just retired
and so he
and how old is he 31 yeah young it's so
much bubble when you see what they do
like dude
if he didn't retire he could have won
for the next four or five years
he just yeah so now who's the guy who
replaces it the guy that beat him not
beat him but uh he took third in 2020
and then won this last 20 21 year justin
medeiros he's got a beautiful mullet
incredible yeah i need i need then to
talk about the uh yeah we're going to
talk about this yeah
with the females yeah she's so yeah this
guy is oh this guy's fantastic yeah
right it looks like he's straight out of
an 80s action movie
he's uh i think he's like 22 and he
has just kind of popped on the scene in
the last two years and now he's like he
looks like theo and michael chandler had
a baby yeah
by the way are these guys the champions
mostly
under six feet
yeah yeah i don't think there's ever
been like rich frowning is about five
eight right yeah five eight five now i
think it's a little taller yeah
there's not like big guys there are like
like brent fakowski's like six foot plus
like i would say sick one maybe six two
and weighs what rare like two twelve
he's kind of an outlier they're they're
outliers there's like no six four two
fifties
no just because i mean i think like you
might have a chance the like 5 8 185
to 200 range is like that's because
there's a lot there's a lot of
gymnastics homeboy is pretty sure so
yeah this guy is very specific about his
nutrients and macros and stuff so they
all they're all over the map all of them
do different things yeah most of them
are i would say a lot of them are just
worried about what they're how much
they're consuming because they just need
calories because they're burning so much
and then some will take time and be like
hey i really need organic raw food to
lock it in so
the paleo thing not so much
it was more of the early days and i
think that that's kind of developed more
to like a ketogenic diet yeah more keto
now yeah so meaning meaning fats and
proteins and very little carbs well no
yeah i mean i think like the the
competitors themselves are doing higher
carbs because they need to sure but as
far as like general crossfitters i think
it's a little bit more yeah i would say
that because i mean
when you're training for health and
longevity that's very different than
training for sport and these guys are
training for sport and so like i think
their diet needs to be very different
than what i would prescribe to like my
dad so do you have a do you have a
dietary philosophy
i have been doing macros for like a long
time so i track like how many pro how
much protein carbs and fat i'm eating
every day how do you do that um i just
use an app and a lot of times i'm on the
road my fitness pal contact me yeah
that's what i use yeah most people i
know who are in really good shape yeah
when i was track macros really it's by
far the best and it's easy it's easy to
stick so you say fats
proteins and carbs yeah and so if i go
to chipotle like all of that's built
into the app and i can just say hey i
got this burrito with just chicken and
the side of this and it's going to be
off a little bit just because i don't
know how much chicken they're actually
putting in but when i'm home like i will
weigh chicken i'll weigh fruity pebbles
at night to make sure i get 45 grams of
fruity pebbles oh wow so that when i'm
home i'm really on on it and then when
i'm on the road i just kind of like
i get what i can get because most of the
time like i just forget to eat i mean
why are you guys so in the crossfit like
what where's this the passion for
crossfit you know what i'm saying
yeah i think it's great don't get me
wrong i like your direct question but
like where i i think it is
someone more balls deep in crossfit
what's funny is like it's not something
like i i played football and when we got
out of college and stuff it was just
kind of like on the rise and i was like
i'm not gonna
train the way i was training when i was
playing football and stuff and this
training program kind of came out and it
was interesting and it was kind of like
that was the sport was the training
and i kind of just like i met heber in
the early days when we started doing
media for crossfit and then we ended up
getting a job and then moving out there
and we kind of just like wrapped our
whole lives around the crossfit
headquarters crossfit headquarters so
that that would i don't know if they're
necessarily based in santa cruz anymore
but that's where we lived for about 10
years and then doing my research so
you're at the crossfit headquarters and
then the owner of what is it the owner
of crossfit at the time yeah at the time
there's the owner of crossfit he was
like hey we're all set on media we're
good get rid of media yeah 2018. uh
what's his name um greg glassman yeah
great glasses
i was a kid didn't he yeah yeah so if
you ever see greg lastman who invented
crossfit i think essentially he's got
he's got uh a bit of a disability yeah
you know can you invent crossfit though
it's weird to say now because it's so
prevalent but i want to say like in the
90s and 2000s and even in the 70s like
oh he's only going to work he has he had
polio though so he has a disability yeah
but he would be coaching athletes
he would be kicked out of gyms for the
style of training they were doing yeah
but the but the the meat and potatoes of
crossfit that that's been around for
hundreds of years so how can he claim
all he did is put in an order and then
develop like i think i think the
philosophy though was that he said you
can get a workout in
three minutes four minutes 15 minutes
that's been around for that'll take for
years well i think the combination of
olympic lifting and and things like
circuit training together so i think the
intensity i think he was the first i
think that they
they claim to to have
defined what fitness is because like
when you would ask somebody what is
fitness in the past they would be like
the act of being fit or x y and z the
actual definition of that i do think he
did he was kind of revolutionary
they did they defined it as uh
constantly varied functional movements
at high intensity so that's kind of like
the whole philosophy of crossfit i mean
you're an athlete so maybe you were
doing
that stuff without realizing it but i
think foreign
like i had been doing burpees i had been
doing like so like i told you before
like i would go swim i would go box i
would go home and lift weights and i was
kind of doing crossfit but it wasn't
organized in a way that like i could do
it all in one space at one time four
times
and so he developed like hey we're gonna
we're gonna train like this we're gonna
put everybody's time on a white board so
they're competing against the
competition community and that
competition drives people to do better
but it was also where where executives
and regular people like myself would
where i was the first time i saw
somebody say well you're going to climb
a rope and run a quarter mile climb a
road run a quarter mile and i was like
that sounds [ __ ] impossible i want to
do that or you're going to do fran i was
like what the [ __ ] is that you're gonna
do thrusters and pull-ups like i i i
personally as somebody you know in
wrestling we did something like that but
not to that degree i think it was like
for people who didn't
know this it was just a it was it was a
new concept because think about every
trainer in the world in la you would
sign up for an hour you go for they they
charge you for an hour all of a sudden
this this thing called the wad of the
day the workout of the day was talking
about some of the workouts were four
minutes but you'd be done with it and
you'd be like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah you
can swore for the next day yourself yeah
i mean
first time i did fran i thought there
was something wrong with my [ __ ]
i went to there's a crossfit gym called
amped in um seattle do you go there
never been it's a great [ __ ] gym and
um
i
joker boy over here i go there and i go
i want to do crossfit and i don't again
i was a little little dabbler and i'm
there are these 26 year olds and we were
doing wall balls and we were doing
pull-ups for time and then some up and
rows or something i'm like i guess i'll
jump in because i'm in shape well i took
all the skin off my hands i took all the
skin i looked down and i i didn't have
skin yeah i was i couldn't hold the mic
bubba i had i i had to wrap my i had to
bandage my hands and i looked like a
boxer i think there's a video of it me i
look like a biggest [ __ ] in the world
and oh did i mention that i pulled my
arms
did i yeah
i have to go to the doctor because i
can't straighten my yeah i pulled them
because they swelled up i don't know if
you've ever done it but i looked like
the nation i [ __ ] i [ __ ] destroyed
myself but it was the first time i've
been like rhabdo my alice
that's basically where you work out so
much and with such high intensity that
like your muscles like turn to liquid
[ __ ]
and your kidney can't your kidneys can't
do anything with it so you go to the dog
so in the early days of crossfit they
almost like were
it was almost like a psa of like don't
get rabdo by doing this because you
could but it was almost like a badge of
honor if like you could do these
workouts
but it was uh
kind of the first extreme fitness that
just like destroyed people but then you
guys have a background in uh film
yeah so i grew up like making videos
like i was when i i was so my older
brother was really into it he's a little
he's like 12 years older than me and he
would be making like uh skits for the
high school assemblies
and at the time it was the 80s so he did
a movie he did a skit called back to the
future and he went back to the future to
find out how he got so cool as a senior
in high school and then i was cast as a
younger version of himself oh so i'm
like did you have that hair that i
didn't but i had some you know some
locks and uh so yeah from that
experience being in front of the camera
i fell in love with the process and like
would edit from vhs tape to vhs tape in
in like the second grade and then made
like skate movies through through junior
high and then just kept it up and
started making like short films in high
school so then when i realized my senior
year of high school that i could do this
as a job
then i put my mind towards okay i want
to try and go to school for this and and
get educated as a filmmaker
you too yeah so like i was just kind of
always drawn to video cameras and stuff
and i remember my
parents had like the giant vhs put up
yeah and i was always like i want to
play with that thing like it was just
something that drew my attention and
then
like middle school i signed up for a
journalism class and they had those like
original mac computers that were like
giant but clear but yeah clear but i had
like video editing software on there and
that was the first time that i
blew my mind of being like i can like
manipulate all this and
control everything and make a story and
that's when i was like that's
if i can figure out a way to do this
because it didn't feel like a job it
felt like something that i could be
creative and
have you guys been to iceland and yeah
you tell me why people from iceland are
that strong and that good yeah i i mean
some in the water it's gotta be like
they're all i think it's the just the
the viking blood they're good at
crossfit some of the bags
so they're also like they have a
different body type don't they aren't
they super thick naturally they're just
am i wrong are they they're thicker and
also like thor the strong man guy like
the mountain from the game of thrones
yeah like he's out of iceland it's land
of the giants did you guys meet him at
the tough mudder yeah yeah
he was there before he got he was there
yeah yeah he's a super nice dude but
bring up some of the women some of the
icelandic
yeah so look up like annie thor's
daughter or catherine
crossover what does the icelandic uh
crossfitters beat the americans so the
the women for a long time like annie won
in 2011 and 12
and then she's been in the sport since
2009 and is still continuing to be on
the podium that's sarah yeah danny is
specifically and then and then her
friend katrin went on and won 15 and 16.
there you go and has been on the podium
a few times
so they've had someone from iceland on
the podium basically or in contention
since 2009 look at her [ __ ] abs look
at that she got the turtle shell and
like i remember her as a rookie coming
out in 2009 not knowing how to do half
the movements and and still being just
insanely fit and she's she had those
you know like a younger version of that
ab
well it's crazy she just she had a kid
last year and she did and everybody was
like
wondering if uh if she was gonna make a
comeback and then she
ended up taking third which is having a
kid after having a kid yeah it was like
a small winner i think everybody kind of
like not necessarily wrote her off but
thought that she was uh well brooke
wells what used to be from what i
remember sleeping with his really
beautiful sexy
crossfit gal but now she's a big time
competitor is that is that she's always
been a competitor she has so like she
came on the scene in a rookie year at
like a lower level tier competition and
set the world record at her very first
event that she competed at is she a tall
woman
no she's like five five ten maybe five
nine again that's pretty tall i mean i'd
say crossfit has the prettiest athletes
yeah i agree they're very pretty yeah
that's a good looking sport about 100 i
think i think for me like why i love it
is is it creates beautiful people
there are gorgeous people right
and by the way in crossfit the rule is
you after your first set you have to
take your shirt off yeah you take a
photo because the cotton restricts your
technology for sure cotton allergies you
got to always lose your clothes i i
don't
let me ask you this you probably can't
answer this but is everybody [ __ ]
everybody because
because they couldn't be better looking
it's like these men and women that look
like like a god was like this is what
you're supposed to look like it's like
the olympics like in where the villagers
yeah it's just like the best athletes in
the world and they have to
provide thousands of cons yeah and they
go through them all elite athletes just
hey [ __ ] hump yeah yeah i mean if
they're not [ __ ] what a waste of a
workout right what a waste of a body
what the [ __ ] are we doing here to you
want to get across the finish line or do
you want to just cross couples then
you're always like around each other
yeah and i'm sure that like you know in
specific gyms or whatever that there's a
lot of uh do they have it only fans
because i'll pay a lot of money just to
be a flyer i'm not sure
some of those women and by the way men i
mean if you i'm a straight man but i
have to say that
you know
i get a little confused looking at that
sometimes yeah like dan bailey is like
one of the poster childs of the men
bring him up he's not competitive dan
bailey
go hold on let's see this only fans
thing she's yeah
no
i mean she might i think she might i'm
not saying
she might have a crossfit membership
yeah she definitely does kettlebell
swings i'm a fan of that
that that's what it is
that's just to work on your flexibility
your lower back flexibility yeah dan
bailey dan bailey yeah yeah so this guy
yeah
he's not the football kicker yeah so
he's one of our really good buddies but
he's just so handsome he's he's built
like a god
yeah yeah he's an attractive human being
well yeah
yeah he almost looks like a bodybuilder
yeah a lot of people all these traps
well that's a bodybuilder and that's all
natural now here's the thing
yeah here's my thing yeah i'm glad you
went together uh i'm not going there i'm
not saying but i was saying that
i would assume just like in all
professional sports
enhancing
performance drugs is part of the game
for some sure because like in any sport
like nfl nba ufc it's just
you know guys some are some aren't i
think i think some bodies are are like
oh let me ask you this without putting
in a weird spot do they how the how
strict the testing
they test and and once a year
no like the so the top elite athletes
get put into a pool and they're tested
fairly regularly right like randomly
like you saw randomly throughout yeah i
think usada does the testing so like
tested within but they do get like i
want to say a 24-hour window notice
and there are people that are very
specific about like hey the testing
protocol is not great but i think for a
young sport that's up and coming like
the test is pretty great it's pretty
decent for yeah and they tested all the
like preliminary competitions and then
they test throughout the entire
competition of the crossfit game i don't
know why they give us i heard the thing
i like just released the house yeah who
cares i agree it's like baseball i don't
give a [ __ ] yeah yeah you don't see the
biggest freaks at the ball as far as so
i i think i
want to agree but i think as a company
crossfit like they're the sport is
supposed to be the tip of the spear of
what the company is about right and it's
a health and wellness company not a
sport company and so like to promote
better health and longevity that would
probably be the wrong idea i think any
time you have any extremes of anything
in you know you're gonna have the
athletes who are competing at the
highest level yeah is a different animal
than the
the people of the sport itself yeah that
people are doing as a you know uh to get
if you want to get in really great shape
and you don't have a whole lot of time
and you want to learn how to eat well
and be in a community yeah your box is
probably a great place to be and i would
say that's probably like you asked
earlier like what is it you liked about
it first like i liked how the people
look doing it yeah the second the
community aspect community is the best
part of the
you guys all seem like you're having
such a blast it looks like the most
positive [ __ ] place with the best
looking people who are healthy as [ __ ]
that's and it's it's literally like a
global family because we we travel all
over the place and wherever we go
there's these gyms and they're super
welcoming and they they
bring you in and me and it's like you're
you're part of the the group you're part
of the family i feel i feel like in greg
if i'm wrong crossfit was like the
hottest thing like five years ago sure
did taylor off a little bit and homeboy
fired the entire immediate yeah yeah
definitely 18 he kind of took a turn
where so
i won't speak to what his thoughts were
but he um they let go of the entire
media department they changed a lot of
the sport and then a year later he went
on and made some remarks on twitter that
were dramatically taken
like he said some racist stuff during
kovid right after uh
george floyd and so the community had
really like stood up against him and he
had eventually like i felt like he felt
like the community had turned his back
down he stole he sold the company
because he's like i don't wanna i don't
wanna deal with this anymore
um so he's no longer in charge of it and
they've now rebuilt their media team and
rebuilt the company but i think that
definitely hurt unfortunately across its
image for a while
like for a while i would say like people
thought it was canceled yeah we in in
2020 it almost thought you you know it
was gonna die you thought that
everybody's gonna boycott it and it was
gonna go away and then i think anyone
who said anything in after that after
the five months after that
you could say anything i just would be
taken out of christ i disagree this one
you can't take out of context scroll up
chin
scroll up i like where you had that be
but not not here so he goes uh we're not
mourning for george floyd i don't think
me or any of my staff are scroll down
can you tell me why i should mourn for
him other than that uh that it's the
what uh the white thing to do on that
give me another reason yes minneapolis
gym owner who had questioned why the
brand hadn't posted a statement born and
that's all he said
uh i mean there was some that was that
was one of a few things he had he had a
double down yeah he had a rough week um
and i would say like
like if you're watching that that's
actually a part of a zoom call that he
had with a bunch of people that someone
recorded and then leaked to the press oh
wow but he
yeah i mean he said some things that
were
i don't know if they're racist but i i
think that he
it it's it's it's a very political like
knowing him as a person knowing him like
i've worked with him and seeing who he
worked with i don't think he's racist
but like i think he made some really
dumb remarks that pushed people along
and unfortunately it affected not just
the company but
thousands of gym owners around the world
you know and so then that's when it was
like
all the gyms were wanting to like take
crossfit off their name because like how
can i support this company if this is
their views on
black lives matter and all and
everything that was happening during
that time
so they've got a new ceo eric rosa who's
done a phenomenal job of helping rebuild
the company and and they have some you
know the one thing i would say about
crossfit as much i'm a huge admirer as i
said i love it um but the
injury is a thing like my joke about
crossfit a lot of times i'll see a lot
of guys like yeah i'm getting back into
it but you know i pulled this or i you
know it's it is so intense that if
you're not [ __ ] careful about it
because the problem is
if you're doing deadlifts for time
everybody i know is competitive like if
we all start doing [ __ ]
i i'm i'm gonna look at me i'm 54 years
old and doing 50 burpees because you
guys are [ __ ] cheering me up
and i got lost in your eyes but the
bottom line is you know
you as as guys or as gals who are
competitive you're gonna [ __ ] and if
you're competing with somebody next to
you it's pretty easy to [ __ ] yourself up
i would say the problem isn't the
programming the problem is ego right 100
so like what you're doing in the gym
should be like if i got hurt and i
wanted to rehab my body i'm probably
going to be doing the same movements but
much lighter yes and so where it becomes
a problem is when you when you have to
be competitive and you have to beat
people in my as i've gotten older in
this in in training that way i've
actually come to enjoy like oh i don't
need to do this as written like i'll
scale the weight back and i don't care
if i'm going to lose this if it means
that i'm going to be better in five
minutes like we just did a workout at uh
in big bear where mars went all out and
he beat me
messed my back
back
like a question mark all week and i was
i was fine i was like okay well i'm glad
i didn't but you know you won yeah yeah
you won you know but i was definitely
damaged
so [ __ ] up yeah it's tricky when will
we learn because you don't learn as you
get older either yeah that's worse
because you always want to yeah and it's
just
yeah and you get more prone but the
thing that's cool is that it's like
scalable from the best in the world they
can program some crazy workout that i
wouldn't even do but then i could be
like okay well i can lower the weight or
i can do a movement that's similar to
what they're doing to kind of solicit
the same response so it's cool that like
my grandma could do a version of a
workout that the best in the world could
do yeah and that's what's cool about it
is there's this like commonality yeah it
could be like i know i understand what
they're doing and like it's it's really
cool because like i you don't get that
in a lot of other sports does crossfit
still have a deal with espn where they
advertise on espn so they had the
crossfit games on espn for a while like
that was one of my first jobs working
for him was helping create a pilot for
that and then i want to say that deal
ended in like 16 or 17. they're not with
like cbs
but i feel like even like the
demographic like there's not a ton of
old people like even if it was just on
youtube live like it would crush
yeah they do have a dude
they
what i love about it also is that like
if you want a great community that's the
other thing if you want to be in great
shape if you want your body to look like
an athlete's body like it's close to it
you know that there i don't think
there's anything better they look better
than most athletes they really do they
really i think the best bodies well that
was like the first thing that i even
noticed was [ __ ] man like the movie 300
that's yeah they all were jumping
crossfit they were all doing like
crossfit style training to look that way
and that's kind of what it blew
same body and by the way fast spinner's
working with a [ __ ] cannon
he's got a dick on him a duck yeah
because it makes you dumb when you see
it
on how they trained for it and i i was
like man i want to train like that and
then i noticed that where they were
training was a high school nearby me
so the gym that the trainer um is a guy
named mark twight who lives in salt lake
city and had a gym there and so i
started kind of looking into that style
of training and my buddy said hey i'm
going to this crossfit gym you should
come and i looked at it and i said that
looks like
how they train for 300 i will be there
tomorrow and and fell in love with it
the first time wow yeah 300 had like a
huge
influence on crossfit yeah everyone's
like how long by the way yeah great
movie not good great movie yeah fun game
changer yeah yeah remember when you
started lift your shield yeah you know
that was this thing is like lift your
shield bro yeah because it was like it
was can't be in our group you can't lift
your shoes
remember the peanut butter falcon like
guy who wanted to be like part of him
he's like lift your shield he's like
he's like can't get the [ __ ] out yeah
get the [ __ ] out of here
that's kind of a great metaphor for life
yeah
yeah it's it's a great it's a great
thing man i'm glad it's still has it so
cause crossfit's still going strong even
after covet because you guys did this
the next documentary did
is it has it been released yet yeah
released in july
yeah yeah because i'm yeah that's
available where you can get on itunes
amazon anywhere you can buy or rent
movies yeah the top athletes i feel like
would be successful in anything they did
though because they're so intense so
like matt
he
yeah they're all freak athletes matt was
like he was on the road to becoming an
olympic weightlifter and go to the
olympics in that oh he ended up breaking
his back um weightlifting and then and
then found crossfit after that and then
and tia talked to me about tia first
time so tia bring her up um gia took
second and 15 and 16. and in 16 she left
the crossfit games to catch a flight
down to brazil to be at the
uh olympics as a weightlifter has gone
on to do incredible things that in the
some of the new zealand or australian
weightlifting uh events and then now is
uh
training to be on the um the bobsled
team for australia for the winter
olympics coming up
so yeah she's won the past five years in
a row and
basically once she won the first one it
was like
nobody else is even coming close now
it's amazing it's like it's literally
like she's like the tiger woods yeah
like it's her and everybody else trying
to get on because she figured it out she
probably did she figured it out because
like to your point people like that know
how to train
better than that's why one of the things
about cejudo because he was a gold
medalist in the olympics that that dude
just knew how to train
where he didn't get injured where he was
just the olympic athletes yeah just
yeah these guys figured it out they just
figure it out this is a different way of
doing it look she's jacked yeah jack
she's sweet and her husband is her
trainer right yeah
i don't know how that works yeah that's
crazy i'd be tough well he's no slouch
either he's kind of a stud but you you
cannot come light in the ass you cannot
come like yeah yeah yeah yeah absolutely
and i would try i would try yeah you're
not
no i i understand i get tried i'd be a
baton you know you know on the [ __ ]
you know whatever that is willing to be
a baton okay
because i'm i'm secure in my masculinity
and she's still competing or she retires
yeah she's
yeah and i don't i mean if she wants to
just win for the next five years she
probably could and she just dominates
yeah like not even close that kind of
training year round right you're just
constantly trying i think that's where
matt and tia really differentiated
themselves and said that
they took an off season like they like
matt would rebuild yeah they would take
from like
from august until really he would start
training again in like almost february
and and he would take that time and he
would know like
when one competitor our friend pat
bellner saw him as a facetime and was
like not only are you the best at
getting fit you're also the best at
getting fat because you've somehow put
on a ton of weight in between like
august and and september like he took a
really strong offseason and that's one
thing that a lot of athletes weren't
able to do is like
that's that's more of a professional
style right exactly like a lot of
crossfit athletes would finish the
crossfit games and not do as well they
wanted and like 10 days later they're
back in the gym crushing their soul
and like that's crazy that's very
interesting though because i must give
their bodies time to rebuild and all the
micro tears and all yeah but if the best
is doing that you think the other
athletes would figure it out but yeah
yeah but also i think like the guys that
are like winning it every year and like
getting like year-round well i think
they're like they're winning and they're
getting paid versus like the rest of the
field if you don't win you're not making
as much money so you're like oh there's
a local competition that i can go to
next week and make some money so you
feel like you're like always ready for
it you're always on like it's like she's
the top she's the tiger woods or the
females she's making good money
making money
what's pretty good money we think
yeah what's the top well like to win i
think you get 330 000 to win the whole
thing but that's like this if you win
the super bowl across yeah so it's not
like other professional sports but
between that and a lot of like
endorsements yeah she probably has
seminars and she does her own
programming and i think that's where
she's really crushing it because i bet
like now that these top athletes like
even
fraser he does a program called hard
work pays off hwpo and
like he was kind of nervous to retire
because he's like i'm going to like
drop down a ton if i if i retire and now
that he's retired and he's doing this
programming more than ever yeah and now
he's he's crushed his program
to hear what they know about diet what
they know about rest yeah pay for the
program daddy yeah that's what they're
doing hwpo yeah because your body will
change dude you think your body is
that enthusiasm hey take your money
slow in the [ __ ]
i've been eating oysters it your
testosterone they're like that's awesome
dude shoot testosterone in your ass
that's the way you get [ __ ] better
every one of my every actor i know if
there's any if there's any [ __ ] going on
in crossfit or professional sports i
promise you hollywood is way worse but
why why wouldn't you
they called me right now like hey dude
you gotta play batman in six months i do
it
i'm like send me all the steroids
i mean it's batman just a jack batman i
just [ __ ] my brother
you know what dude you know what i'm
glad you said that yeah because i've
ever leave you about this is my natural
voice i've been up and i i i keep it
higher so i don't understand
yeah it's like
i'm batman i wore my feet
yeah michael keaton was a weird batman
he sucked he's all tiny he's losing his
hair
he's the original actually like ben
affleck a little bit right guys
uh what else
i actually kind of know him no you don't
actually you know hold on right now i
got one better for you call him right
now you were there we were at we went we
were at um that place on montana
and chris henshi who is brooke shields
husband he's uh he's a writer and i know
him he goes brian i go what's up we're
at that restaurant yeah you sit with
michael keaton do you remember that yeah
he was there i would never say i've met
him and know him i had a long talk with
him i was there with you it was pretty
quick
he was like yeah cool
you went like this one very cool no
no because then we have we had a time
share in uh tahoe yeah and we skied
together
i was there when you met him we did
crossfit i was there and he was
literally
quick
they were in the middle of conversation
he's like thank you very much yeah uh
excuse me i get the double digits excuse
me but if you remember i lived in the
neighborhood and i saw him other times
and we spoke okay about stand-up and
other things now because he used to be a
comment he started as a comment so
that's what we
you guys are gonna come to improv
tonight that's where mike keaton started
oh wow yeah yeah oh you're gonna be are
you doing the improv yeah yeah theo
chris and i oh no [ __ ] i'm doing laugh
factory tonight yep down in long beach
okay yeah
all right far away yeah
we'll see all right let's do some
current events what do you guys think
current events maybe back in early 2000s
remember the blackberry
blackberry phones yeah blackberries
revolutionized how we communicate dude i
had one a lot of people still use them
but it wasn't long before steve jobs and
apple thought they could outperform them
with their new phone with their own
phone talk about the iphone dude yeah
sure in an all-new season of business
wars all right you'll hear about how
blackberries and iphones battled for
their shares of emerging mobile phones
business wars is that a podcast it's a
podcast dude all right podcasts on
business wars it's iphone versus
blackberry you hear how blackberry the
phone favored by presidents wall street
and top government officials went out of
style dude spurred apple to push the
envelope by developing technology
that we're talking about the iphone well
once iphones came along the blackberry
was like a piece of rusty machinery yes
that i would put in my i have one i
think in my old desk that i've never
looked yeah the big antennas they were
cool man listen to business wars iphone
versus blackberry podcasts on apple
podcast amazon music or you can listen
ad free by joining laundry plus in the
wondry app here's the thing about
edibles dude dude i stay away from
edibles because you never know you get
too high dude the next thing i know you
can overdose on thc and what happens is
you have the worst four five six seven
eight nine ten hours of your life it's
happened to me due to anxieties through
the roof you want edibles you can trust
you want to make you when you take it
you want to know the control you want to
know how much is in it dude well what
what do we do what do we do about it
well dude what you're going to do you
need the perfect kind of medium high
right you hit up our friends at diet
smoke that's diet smoke for their
delicious delta 8 thc gummies diet smoke
isn't light it's just right that's right
yep delta 8 is some simple all right
it's slightly less potent than thc it's
well it's a less potent th yeah thc but
delta nine that's one thing they're
natural
it's a cannabis plant but diet smoke
extracts their delta eight from hemp
okay that i guess there's a big
difference now they call it a loophole
maybe but it's a secret recipe you get
it's a smooth stable and most
importantly it's
not gonna freak out man it's nice diet
smoke is legal in most states it's
non-prescription just check diet smokes
website to see if they ship to their
delicious gummies to your state now
probably ask yourself does diet smoke
really get you high of course the high
you get with diet smoke is best
described is somewhere between the
chillness of cbd and the classic stone
feeling of regular wheat you got to try
this the best of both worlds honestly
all right so when cbd isn't enough and
drizzle thc is too much enjoy the smooth
buzz of diet smoke all right each gummy
is infused with 10 milligrams of delta 8
thc all right you know what they say
buy american get high with americans
it's crazy everyone's from american
grown hemp yeah dude yeah yeah and it's
and guess what they're legal so go to
dietsmoke.com use the promo code fighter
for 20 off your order that's 20 off
dietsmoke.com promo code fighter for 20
off diet smokes delta 8 thc gummies are
not for use or sale to people under 21
please use responsibly on it maybe you
think it's coincidence the buttery bros
we're in studio and we're pitching some
workout advice right now huh i i i want
a body like the buttery bros you gotta
go look you need help with your
supplementation if you want great
exercise equipment if you want if you
want kettlebells if you want mesas if
you want focus you've got alpha brain if
you want mood and sleep you've got new
mood yeah protein we have protein they
got amazing protein like whey protein
plant-based protein they got protein
bars protein bites
sweetened with monk fruit it never ends
you want coffee you got tea they got you
don't wait till january 1 to get your
thick ass in shape all right get going
right now they got fitness carol they
got streaming fitness we got it all
there's no reason not to be in shape
don't wait till january first to decide
don't let me get out
never go to on it.com fighter for 10 off
the entire damn site that's on it.com
fighter for attempts off the entire damn
site current events uh so
yesterday you sent us this article and
it's so weird apparently there is
backlash for this k-pop band called
purple kiss because in one of their
promotional photos one of the girls is
seen wearing like this army jacket
outfit and there's a nazi symbol on it
and i guess it's a swastika yeah it's
their exact logo yeah
like huge pop bands they do this and
then they get all this like heat and
they're like my bat but they just want
it for the attention because what's
funny about what you said one time and
you didn't mean it and you loved fashion
and you said something to the effect you
were like the nazis were terrible but
their uniforms were kind of lit they're
uniforms
and the best fashion in history
i don't think that's right hugo boss
made them like yeah and that's the
fashion's pretty legit i mean yeah
that's terrible people but legit outfit
yeah go ahead and cover it so they do
this on purpose they do yeah because it
gets attraction and then they just
talk about another pr team's like oh
sorry we didn't mean to do that we
didn't realize that why they do the nazi
symbol and then they put u.s air force
on top of it yeah i'm like so this is
like it's so strong why why uh why is
there that picture is that photo shop
that nazis no no that's real on the
actual outfit oh so like they changed
one patch
that's that's how they that's how they
fix it that's the luftwaffe oh they
apologize
that's the luftwaffe and they bombed a
lot of innocent people with that
it's crazy man but you think about this
purple kiss man you ever heard of him
never no have you
you guys are in there no but i remember
remember when i worked at k-pop you know
what i'm saying i saw this happen before
with other artists with other groups
they do like before [ __ ] yes very
controversial stuff and they go i didn't
know i didn't know and they apologized
and then everyone said they know what
they're doing let me see their music but
they know what they're doing but then
they come up because of it yeah they get
more popular obviously the more like
we're talking about right now yeah like
purple kiss would never make this
internationally she wasn't rocking that
nazi true outfit and they have i'm sure
they have nothing to do with it's just
their producers and people you know in
the company yeah they put this on you
remember ozz that showa's prison show
yeah so back in the day i did an episode
a season of it and uh we had the aryan
brotherhood and the actors played
aryans and they all would get these
semi-permanent tattoos they had to get
tattoos that you know represent that and
but they last for a long time so they
would be walking around with swastikas
well we're long sleeves though you know
yeah so one of the actors sweet guy
sweet guy he's on the subway in new york
and he told me that he was holding on to
the thing and his sleeve was here and he
had just this giant swastika and this
black dude looked at me like you got a
lot of nerve coming on this [ __ ]
train with that [ __ ] bro
yeah point
dude this is fake i'm an actor i'm on a
show called oz and the guy i've never
heard of the show he's just fine but oh
damn yeah but they used to have to walk
around just covered in swastikas
you'll be wearing all the clothes for a
long time yeah yeah because you can't
explain that away it's kind of hard i'm
an actor yeah uh yeah what else you got
jen
so we talked about dave chappelle's
former high school a while back and they
actually released a statement recently
that they're still gonna go forward and
name the theater that dave chappelle had
gotten a lot of funding for after the
comedian regardless of because the
school is like there's like seven kids
upset yeah [ __ ] off that's social media
in a nutshell correct
apparently dave chappelle also went back
to his hometown to speak to some of the
parents who had donated who now after
his special wanted to take their funding
back
they he sat down with them and had a
conversation about his special to try to
ease their minds too so he's kind of
going out of his way to make people feel
better and have a conversation but
besides you guys on social media in the
crossfit community who's who's the
social media kind of
blitzkrieg yeah
is there any like outliers is there
anyone who's like polarizing crossfit
it's a pretty welcoming and loving
community i don't know if there's anyone
out there like really there's no one
that gets like a lot of hate or anything
no i mean it wouldn't be tough to hate
him yeah i think you're so muscular you
suck the only thing would be like
someone that tested positive for
something in the past that's yeah yeah
like we have a guy that tested positive
he served his four-year band and now
he's on his way back here is a long
[ __ ] long time and he's on he's on
his way back to compete and i'm like i'm
kind of excited to see what he does four
[ __ ] years to hand somebody for for
taking
something that's [ __ ]
i'm sorry how about six months six well
i mean i'm kind of everyone's gonna do
it yeah i mean six months isn't even
even
six months now all right a year a year
is a long time i would say two years
four [ __ ] years
you're mean no listen i think they
should [ __ ] open up the floodgates
okay the [ __ ] they want but i mean
first of all it's like
i hate when people are like judgmental
if there's anybody in the community he's
like
like shut up like four years he only
knocked you like that guy i'm sure he
posts some people like oh the only
reason you're gonna finish first is
because you took right yeah i mean take
all the stuff you'll never get you won't
even qualify for the game yeah
what else you got yet
this is another update in the jesse
smollett situation it turns out that the
two brothers uh
made a statement to police officers
saying that he actually staged like a
like a test run before the actual
incident tight move so he had gotten
both of the trainers in the car they
drove around a driver breakdown about
like hey this is where this is gonna
happen and then i'm gonna leave from
here you guys leave from here he's so
dumb did he not think he was gonna get
caught he's so dumb uh two brothers
actually said the reason why
jesse did it based off of what he they
were told is he wasn't happy with how
the show empire were
kind of uh handling the hate mail that
you would get and so to counteract that
he made the fake like mega letter with
the drawing of him hell yeah and then he
was trying to like teach them a lesson
he's an idiot yeah he sucks i don't know
why this is going i don't know
he's like dude hey bro you suck if i was
the judge you get out of here you that
sucks yeah don't get all the taxpayers
money like this is cash
yeah yeah yeah it's ridiculous
way to [ __ ] up your career too oh my
goodness
[ __ ] up your career oh yeah and there
are some sex crazed elephants currently
in africa in south africa specifically
because it's their mating season there
was a safari group of i believe like
college students going out and a
elephant went after them in a sex-crazed
uh
trying to hump him yeah
ain't saving you they were trying to say
it was like pent-up sexual energy uh so
i suggested nothing so big almost
happened to me
with an elephant or just like a dude
that's so scary oh that's so [ __ ]
scary
man that is
musical why is it musical friendly i
know that's like that's tasty probably
playing on the jeep
oh my god
see but this is what i want if i pay for
a safari it turned out you want a little
date i want some [ __ ] yeah it'll turn
the jeep over and then oh yeah yeah here
we go oh there you go there you go yeah
it's not good
that lady runs not incredible she's not
yeah you're not in shape [ __ ] she runs
off seven flat foot well she's just easy
to catch damn oh man that truck's got it
the music's so weird that's a terrible
thing yeah
you know what you cannot bring around
elephants
you know what you don't want to have in
that cheap with you a dog you know what
they do
you got a rottweiler in there or
something they go oh your eyes are in
the front of your head you're a predator
oh cool very cool watch this they'll
reach in and grab that dog with their
trunk and throw that [ __ ] thing
really stomp it to death yeah they'll
kill your dog it's like a real problem
like elephants elephants are the biggest
[ __ ] in the animal kingdom anybody
who's been on safari knows that they are
we we were
in a jeep like that and they were it was
it was me it was with michael keith yeah
thank you
michael keaton
i forgot that michael was there because
we did we went down together but we're
good friends yep and then you almost
died by an elephant well we had done it
we had done a crossfit thing and i did
my friend in one minute 30 seconds
and then uh and then the elephants were
the adolescents where it was mating
season and they were all bunched up and
then they were trumpeting and uh
uh
it wasn't like that but they were close
and they were
trumpeting at us they're aggressive they
were aggressive in the area
if i pay for that i want some [ __ ] it's
scary though yeah because that jeep
ain't saving you
i mean i'll jump out they grab you bro
the elephant yeah grab you
pig and they get mad at you and they're
like the guy thinks he's you're 250
that's what i want on those uh
adventures like i want to see a lion
destroy a dare i need some [ __ ] man when
elephants get a hold of you though it's
a bad situation have you ever seen don't
watch those videos but don't no you just
step on it they'll mash it up
they mash it in to butter they make they
make brendan jam out you that'd be cool
yeah a spreadsheet
yeah we'll just get you
all right uh lebron james has covered
he's gonna miss some games
all right very good for him
is he is he my age
no i'm just saying because when he was
you guys have the same hair
how old is he now
damn near late late 30s yeah 37 36
36 okay
younger than i thought those are some
deep lines
see chris cuomo gets suspended it's
ridiculous
my thing is with that it's like it's his
brother his brother people like this
isn't journalism it's like who wouldn't
help his brother i'm like but all he was
doing is like trying to give his brother
a heads up he did what you're supposed
to use like his resources to make sure
his brother's not completely [ __ ] yeah
it's tough it's [ __ ] man
like i don't know i i think i like that
relationship definitely in a
relationship
who had a bigger fall off than them
remember when the pandemic started yeah
on cnn together
we all loved they were like yeah dude he
want a [ __ ] emmy for his the way he
handled the goddamn kovit i like chris i
mean i think i like both i'm not crazy
about cnn's politics a lot of times or
their take on things but yeah i think as
far as bro i have a brother i get i do
the same [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah but to suspend
them over that yeah and and and worth it
anyway you st you you you help your
brother
what would you do for your bro what
would your bro do for you yeah my
brother hide a body yeah
i'd do it for you you and i are for i i
would do it for you what i'm gonna i'm
gonna i can't get the [ __ ] out of here
i i i spent him over that of course
because because you know
i think too though part of it is that
his uh ratings are super bingo that's
what they said super late it was taken
care of they were super high no it was
tanking in the last few months
yes yes allegations and that it's easier
for them to get rid of him that way
instead let's say he has a huge contract
i didn't know that yeah his ratings are
in the tank now trump's gone cnn ratings
this gets more views than cnn yeah wow
but he was he was for a while he was
doing pretty good but tucker carlson
destroys him you know has the biggest
late show
uh laura ingram no no no no i'm talking
like tonight like john kimmel
uh jimmy fallon
um colbert
um the dude he has a uh tonight show on
fox del mar no no not bill maher the guy
the guy who has the tonight show on fox
oh it starts with a g i forget what it
is but he has the highest ratings wow
kind of conservative yes colbert
yeah now that trump they don't have like
trump
but then they still they're still doing
it yeah colbert bummed out about that
kyle ridden house [ __ ] like it's like oh
he he he bumped me out yeah i'm like
come on i used to think he was he's
[ __ ] hilarious and i don't know it
was just weird i just want to say how
impressed i am with how many tabs you
have open right now i know that's why i
have a strong mac
we don't [ __ ] around bro yeah with a
crossfit
a lot of [ __ ] tabs there bro i know
it's a ton
what else you got jen um
oh thanks dude uh so jack dorsey stepped
down from ceo why do you step in from
twitter oh this [ __ ] is super toxic and
it's going down a weird road and i'm
gonna back out before this thing gets
[ __ ] before we all get sued he thinks
that founders should always not stay
forever because they only have one sort
of like you know view they want to open
it up to
costa rica and he just spends his time
surfing now i mean he's super rich of
course yeah
and plus there's like a lot of in the
world twitter is known as like this real
hateful place now and
and he he always his whole thing was
like
i don't get in politics it's always
freedom of speech we're not going to
limit anybody and then trump like you're
out of here it's like well he's the
president of the united states
we know we don't have a voice i think
they just announced today that they're
gonna they will delete posts and
pictures and stuff if you if you like
don't want your photo on tweeted they
will go and delete it right oh wow i
didn't see that yeah they're really hard
though
yeah it's really hard though because
they have about
i think they have like
10 000 or even less people that do that
and there are something like like
facebook took down did you remember this
facebook took down a quarter
billion pages
uh in a year that's how crazy these bots
and ai are like all these troll farms
and all these fake twitter accounts so
it's and all these attacks it's really
hard for them to get to it
really hard but yeah
so i guess the uh silencing of people
can get worse with this new guy that's
what they're saying is that what they're
saying
yeah i thought it was i thought you were
saying if somebody's making fun of you
you can get no no i think it's it's just
one thing wait so what wait what
political career
with support i think a lot of this is is
a reaction to the fact that so many of
these troll farms from other countries
are wreaking havoc so it really is a
problem the the facebook pages um rogan
was uh posting about this and on his
podcast three fourths of all the most
pop three quarters of the most popular
african-american pages on facebook are
controlled by eastern european troll
farms russian troll farms wow um i think
it's 15 of the 19 top christian facebook
pages are troll farms so these are not
even american what they're doing and
you'll see like you'll see black people
calling for a white genocide that's not
black people that's that's china or
russia but this is china
russia's plan they thought they they
said like americans always like
look at like the next day and russia and
china are looking 20 years from now yeah
and the way to make america implode is
by making pin us against each other yeah
just radicalizing veterans that's the
other thing there's this whole move to
so who do you want to radicalize people
are no violence who own guns so you want
to radicalize that quadrant and then
radicalize that millions of them so so
so then you're that's why those those
algorithms push you in an extreme
direction so there's money in polarizing
yeah there's not money and taking people
together yeah and they're scared and the
other thing that they were saying was
that
like a magic trick um social media these
engineers understand your brain better
than you do
meaning
it's like all these companies it's
called a race down the brain stem
because they know that your brain reacts
to a narcissistic thing you get addicted
to how many likes you have you get
addicted be able to scroll you have and
so now china in if you're a tic toc user
and you're under 14 you're off there is
no tick tock for you after 10 o'clock
at night uh they if you're scrolling
there's a they make you wait i think
almost a minute between every five
between every five households
and then you can only have 40 minutes of
like [ __ ] and the rest on tick-tock
they have you have to do science
experiments
um patriotism or one other thing so
fascinating yeah so china was like this
is a major problem for our kids they're
getting they're it's bad for their
brains they're getting addicted they're
not paying attention to their studies or
their families or their community and
they're like in china
china goes hey no more for us it's like
it's a whole democratic property
protest yeah yeah it's a real problem
though because because there's so much
money in making like the the the saying
is we have paleolithic brains medieval
institutions god like technology
and now
more and more
bad information or good information can
get into the brains of a billion people
that fast so the dissemination of
information has never been faster and it
can be very very
dangerous
if you take that troll farms and ai so
so you don't even know if the arguments
there's a fake argument on reddit that
got real that got traction this is
another thing we're talking about a fake
argument on on reddit
and it was all ai it was [ __ ] she's a
robot
we're the infancy stage of it too like
yeah it's going to be bad not like that
10 years from now they can like robots
can recreate now very much so that's
awesome remember when uh when uh mark
zuckerberg when facebook had the two
robots talking they let them talk and
after an hour they're trying to figure
out how to like take over everything
like oh [ __ ] and they pulled the plug
the robots with an hour talking to each
other yeah like right how do we get rid
of humans and they're oh this isn't good
yeah yeah they had to pull the plug and
then this yeah this is posted the other
day this is insanity yeah
robots that can reproduce
xenoblades i mean i've seen terminator i
know how to sound well yeah but if you
talk too much these these theoretical
mathematicians at elon musk and stuff
they were talking about how
we're already in this
this has already happened and what we're
doing as smart machines is just making
we're recreating reality and we're going
to make smarter versions so the reality
all of us know it's very possible we are
in a simulation it's very possible we're
already we're already very advanced
holograms so what is matter matter has
matters not really what you think it is
it's just the electromagnetic field
between things that creates and i always
say this only rich people say we're in a
simulation like if you go to mcdonald's
guys like not like yeah this simulation
i gotta pay my bills
yeah you know it's only the super elite
like we're in a simulation like nah
[ __ ] you're so rich out of touch yeah
but it is weird that we're doing this
stuff and creating
robots that are more and more human-like
yeah it's not good and creating it's
[ __ ] where does it go the pros and
cons it's like pros all right i guess we
have to
you know cook our own food and stuff and
then help us out around the house cons
they take over yeah
they get rid of huge
secret help i mean that's like jumping
out of plane pros
froze i get hair like dragon rush no
adrenaline rush simulate hair like
cons died yeah yeah
figured out you mess with machines and
you're no more like i guess these people
are the smartest in the world i guess
what's the upside man we're all right we
don't need robots why do we need robots
the revelations
right to replace all humans in the
workforce
i mean why do you want robots i don't
know
she's just gonna make humans obsolete
automate every job nuts i don't know
it's funny like even checking your own
[ __ ] out at ralph's like at the checkout
stand
yeah just getting paid to do it yeah you
go leave you used to be able to do that
it leaves us more time to to do what
it's going to get closer
and argue yeah
do better crossfit
yeah [ __ ] get my friend time down
you told me you had a sub five friend
time it's a four three no what's the
pros do six i think i mean the fastest
world is like sub two
but like for for the general population
of sub 5 fran is that's impressive it's
unheard of
but but it's pretty rare yeah i would
say it's very respectable it's a
respectable time hey i would say yeah i
think you got it i was not
i was 45 but i don't think he gots it
how about that i don't think that'll
prove that again now i would love to see
it i think i could do right now i think
so i just did i just did a friend
it took me a while it took me
seven minutes
and uh and i was dying so but if i
really but again i'm older if i try to
start working at it it'll be but i don't
think i could do i think i could do sub
five i think i could get i can get
something if i if i yeah i think if you
train for it you guys i think i could do
that i might
i might try it i could i could maybe do
a sub five
if if you guys were watching and you had
cameras on me yeah yeah it was tyrion's
eyes human height man and i got julian's
eyes
don't challenge me because i'm gonna
[ __ ] myself up dude
i feel like you're always
when i heard how tough it is
no bubba i did uh i did three minutes
did michael keaton record it yeah
michael keaton was spotting my hips but
uh
yeah i think i did i did that but i
worked at it i obsessed over it a little
bit i told you when fran when it was
fran time my heart would start beating
well yeah you know you're about to step
into the lions then yeah for sure
yeah i mean uh
who somebody was there
i climbed a rope i did a i did a rope
thing
i remember there's something under a
minute how many times can you do under a
minute i remember i got really good at
climbing rope thing yeah
i got obsessed with that
i did 40 kipping pull-ups without
stopping once that's a good number
that's really good 40th birthday that's
good is that good yeah what do you what
but what do you guys do you [ __ ]
[ __ ] i haven't done a mac set of
pull-ups in a long time but i think at
the time it was like 63. god damn that's
a lot i'm really light like that's like
that's not really like that's a lot of
pull-ups 40 is uh
that i was just you know yeah mind you
these are keeping pull-ups so it's not
like a strict thing yeah it strikes very
but
i was doing some i was doing butterfly
but you're allowed to keep in uh
crossfit right yeah
but you know crossfit chipping those
kipping ones are a little annoying to me
like i was doing
i was i was swinging back and bringing
it up but the these guys
get it real it's like it's like it's
really a weird bring up kipping pull-ups
because some of these things are like
because you've done i've said like
butterflies he's done you know i've seen
him do i beat you but i've seen him do
uh when we were with tim tebow you did
33 pull-ups both 32 pull-ups without
shopping yeah not kipping straight up
yeah yeah
that's a lot
yeah he's getting a tutorial on the
whole thing that's probably what we want
to see jim we want to see like them like
compete in it
just search chris spieler 100 pull-ups
chris bueller chris spieler chris
it's not the kind of pull-ups that's it
right there there was some crossfit kid
at uh zoo culture and he was filming
himself he did a three thousand points
that third one down spieler was a
wrestler spieler spieler uh yeah was a i
think a high-level wrestler yeah so his
goal in this video back in whatever
that's 2000 isn't he incredible
he was trying to do a hundred straight
yeah
seattle is a park city it's not really a
pull up bubba that doesn't count in any
facet where i come from i agree
just not i don't his chin isn't above
the bar no i think his chin's above the
bar there's the bad end we call that
swinging yeah we call that monkey bar
swinging
but i would say like okay it's not easy
i do pull ups like this but i'm also
really freaking good at strict pull-ups
yeah yeah so i
encourage someone to do this if they
couldn't do really good strict pull-ups
yeah i mean by the way by the way i
don't see his chin going above i got a
problem with that uh it's it's getting
there kind of it's a mind you it's a low
camera angle so you'd have to have like
a gopro up on the bar i'm looking at it
yeah i'm kind of like being on this it's
not sorry
we got to get a little higher all right
chris he's in salt lake right he's in
park city yeah that's right
good dude
yeah i'm sure it seems like dude
terrible pull-up form but um what else
you got chad it's a lot of pull-ups
i did 40 that were not like that i did
40 right
if you're doing a c-kit pull-up which is
like you you come down you swing through
you come up 40 at that is really hot
that's what i did i did i did some they
were they were way better than that but
i promise you they were way better than
that [ __ ] pull up i would i wouldn't
count those as polos huh no that's not
pulling either the that's what's funny
is like we'll put the like whatever
video on youtube or whatever and people
see the pull-ups they're like not a
single pull-up was done that yeah yeah
everybody said i probably wrote that
comment yeah yeah
everybody's such a dick i'll post a
shooting thing and every [ __ ] cop
navy seal yeah you're [ __ ] hand heavy
but hey i don't care
i'm not in combat you [ __ ] yeah don't
correct my [ __ ] shooting you're
slapping the trigger yeah if you're i'm
very aware i'm not a [ __ ] dumb video
that's when all right i get [ __ ]
murdered and i do it on purpose and i'm
like bring it come at me yeah
yeah
all right um
you guys are all fans of the rock
obviously right yeah
he looks older than me but go on okay so
he posted that um the red notice movie
with him and ryan reynolds
is the most watched movie of all time on
netflix which has like 328 million
hour views yeah viewing hours yeah
that's great hey do you know how many
people watch squid games that's why i
brought this up 26 billion yeah so okay
so this article was from like uh half a
month ago right so it's one point one
point six five billion hours streamed in
the first four weeks
and red notice is a month basically the
same time but then brian you mentioned a
while ago
you said like million seconds is like 11
days a billion seconds is like 32 years
so that shows you how much of a
difference is that you're supposed to
talk about games is more ten hours
international right because it looks
like you have the the
you know korea and asia but i mean asia
watches netflix too but there's also a
lot more content i'm trying to i've gone
down the rabbit hole of that true story
it's such a good thing the kevin hart
show it's so good what episode are you
doing i'm i'm about to start the third
one okay so yes you got a little ways to
go it's good though yeah takes your turn
it makes me it [ __ ] me up because i
like him so much
it's so well done
but also being the most watched movie on
uh netflix name another major movie on
netflix go original netflix movie
netflix oh bird the bird box yeah bird
box box bird box that's pretty good
that's the only one i can think of
how the harder they come excursion or
something with chris hemsworth that was
the other big one that came out
extra attraction yeah
they're all excited about it yeah that
was a good one
yeah it was a good action movie wasn't
outpost a netflix movie
i didn't see outpost does it have to be
enough this is honestly that's what
has been rich that's an original you're
just saying that there's not a lot
of there's not a ton don't you wrong 328
million is [ __ ] insane but i think
they're starting to ramp up how much
they have there's a leonardo dicaprio
jennifer lawrence movie coming out soon
yeah
i mean we got three powerful people
there so of course yeah
yeah did anyone watch it though because
i didn't watch it
i'm not going to lie it was probably one
of the worst movies
i'd imagine it would be kind of bad red
notice i have no desire yeah no it's
just not my cup of tea it was fun i
watched it all you saw was fun it was um
what's it about you know ryan reynolds
cracks me up but it's the same i've seen
them i've seen them do that movie what's
the rock doing beating people up he's
just like a guy who's that he's a cop
he's a he specializes as an art theft
yeah ryan reynolds in our theft and he's
just always like god damn it i gotta
[ __ ] now i gotta run and catch this
helicopter in midair again
june bullets and ryan reynolds was like
huh good to see you you look fantastic
yes i got a joke yeah yeah they broke
out of a russian prison yeah i'm also a
castle i'm all set
i'm
crab onto a pine tree i've never seen
that again yeah
uh so this is just dr oz
bidding to be a u.s senate
or be in the u.s senate hard pass in
pennsylvania hard pass
conservative guy
that one hit hard
um
let's see here hey chad yeah i could
feel
brennan's bored energy i know hit me in
the face you hit me in the face after
hit you in the face yeah you know
dr oz is running for the i'm all right
dude you if you announced dr oz died out
of the same right now there's no one
who's like i mean do we get that doctor
i don't know just shut you down i know i
can start getting sentimental i'm like
yeah you know for the first time i
actually felt gay
wow
is it that great though because it's so
it's an hour i think it's four hour
final it's an hour flight roughly it's a
thousand dollars and then you take a
private flight up it's a cessna and you
can have sex in the back of it but where
does it land do they provide their trust
i mean it's in vegas it's just vegas to
vegas it just flies
flies in the air you guys have sex and
then you just provide the women or is it
i guess they don't provide the women you
have a bunch of people just [ __ ] on a
plane or is it you have the whole plan
yourself hopefully yourself except for
the pilot so the pilot has a curtain
that divides you guys but he has
noise-cancelling headphones on don't
hurt
just a curtain because it's a small
plane yeah this sounds suspicious i tell
the pilot like hey bro if you want to
look back pretty weird
i paid a thousand dollars you're welcome
you're welcome and thank you
yeah yeah
we're going to flavor town there was a
service in uh i know in wall street that
they were there was a van that would
pick guys up after work and there was a
girl in there mm-hmm and you'd have sex
in the van
no that's a porno dude no that's a
that's important
yeah well they had that
that was a thing in new york for a while
yeah it's a foreign it's a big thing on
youpor yeah well there you go where
there's it's like a hot girl in a taxi i
gotta have any money i don't know what
i'm gonna do and he's like you don't
have anybody yeah man
he's british just with a heavy british
dick he said you don't have any money
i'm gonna pull over we can figure some
way to pay this shot come on in yeah all
right yeah this little little thing yeah
then he gets backed i'm like man that's
the most room i've ever seen in a taxi
it's a lot of room it's not very
realistic yeah i used to think it's real
it's [ __ ] the air all right yes uh
watch out for that disbelief there let
us get you i'm bored with that okay so
this is kind of
anticlimactic but sort of kind of cool
at the very end so a newborn giraffe
gets attacked by a lion i'll play the
video for you and it's miraculously
survives right well they have to walk
right away obviously because [ __ ]
everything's trying to kill him oh [ __ ]
so you'll see it here
okay
how [ __ ] up is nature nature i know so
fault there he goes oh [ __ ]
it killed my chin no we'll see you watch
here
let me fast forward so he has him there
wait that baby draft survives this so
leaves him alone there he's playing
possum watch watch
drags it again all the way over here
look how many cars like land rovers out
there yeah more mama giraffes like what
are you guys watching so it's right
there just laying down that's a cougar
why does the mom kick him in the [ __ ]
snout i know it's tough that's a lie so
then she's trying to yeah shoot him away
so it's just sitting there then he gets
up it's watching
yeah i don't think he's okay though i
think no he's playing blossom doug yeah
so he gets back up baptism by fire ain't
it
wow
he's a little [ __ ] up i don't think
he's so what happens afterwards
is he walks into
the lake or the pond oh that's not good
an alligator it's not okay crocodile he
drowns
he drives that's how he dies absolutely
he was enabled he was able to survive
the lion attack no he wasn't and then it
just peacefully drowns himself
no
i know that was a plot
let me get in the water
where's the crocodiles man that's
crocodile food
yeah yeah that's not a good time he's
probably okay mom i'm just gonna cool
off for a second here give me give me a
few minutes cycle love love there it
goes
that was the end of it that's it yeah
well that's what happened that's how he
died that's how he got drowned
getting ass first by a lion [ __ ]
first minute out of the [ __ ] wounds
yeah
god nature's a [ __ ] you've got a
very baby in the hospital bubba that's
what i want
man you got to go to a veteran is that
it that's pretty much it all right kids
um
tonight i'm at the improv tonight but
that's sold out that's with you and
chris but uh taking a little december
i'll just be doing local shows in la but
dania florida fort lauderdale florida
december 30th through january first
bringing the new year with your thick
friends here and then justin oh this is
news to me just announced rally north
carolina january 16th
like rallies definitely say raleigh
though i don't know
nope you're going to say wrong you're on
that draft you're going to correct
yourself right now
no don't die no don't travel all right
jay60 january 8th then charlotte north
carolina justin
two north carolinas back to back way to
go uh charlotte north carolina january
23rd january 22nd
either way man i'm in [ __ ] florida
december 30 through january 1st you just
take a just take a flight back right
back across that's a short flight that's
good guys great news first of all
december 15th i'm not well do you know
what this friday boca raton laughing
spree comedy festival already i think
almost sold out then we got december
15th the chop the chow house the child
the sixth
in ventura i me and a very special guest
i just found out uh surprise guest is
going to be very exciting is it done
i'll be there i'm not saying it's a you
said last night it's one of your
favorites no oh really yeah uh it's been
a surprise guest and uh that's going to
be really fun i'll tell you more as i
get along but december 15th the chow
house i think it's man dragon [ __ ] i
can't remember what that thing is i'll
put it up on my thing go to chop it's a
great cell dude [ __ ] anyway
is there a big deal i'm gonna
get it anyway back to uh and then i'm in
uh i'm in kansas city good yeah december
17th uh 18th and 19th and then salt lake
city wise guys would there go boys
yeah i'm doing fran there and uh it's
going to be great in oklahoma city we're
doing me and dove are going to do uh new
year's city news uh chappelle lacy is in
san jose improv tonight one show only is
headlining in san jose go see him fam
boys we love you man you guys thank you
they can find you the buttery bros on
youtube other girls on youtube instagram
everywhere
you're all over the place it got so
blonde in here and i'm happy about it
all right yeah glad to come in here
thank you guys for coming on man you
guys really appreciate it